Throughout the story and the different adventures
of the straw hat crew, there is a symbol that
appears in seemingly unrelated places over
and over again.
It’s a big sphere with 8 satellites around
it.
This symbol appears on Skypea in the crest
of the shandians, in the flag of Alabasta
and even in Wano, where it’s part of the
Kozuki crest.
Now, what sort of meaning could this symbol
possibly have to connect these 3, honestly
quite different places?
Could it actually be that, without us realising
it, Oda has already subtly revealed the symbol
of the ancient kingdom?
The people probably most literate in the history
of the world, next to maybe the Gorosei and
Imu, were the scholars of the island of Ohara.
Inside their library, we can see an enormous
Globe, that you’re probably familiar with,
that seems to show the one piece world surrounded
by multiple spheres.
Now similarly to OUR scientific history, it’s
of course entirely possible, that the scholars
of Ohara simply believed the earth to be the
centre of the solar system and these objects
are the planets circling the earth.
However, I PERSONALLY think it is not at all
far fetched to assume that they were actually
WAY more sophisticated than that.
This would mean that these orbs would in fact
have to be multiple moons, circling the planet.
Now, if that were to be the case, how is it
that we only ever see 1 single moon in the
sky at night throughout the entire story;
the one moon that we know from Enel’s cover
story, that he calls Vearth?
Now we know for a fact, that this moon did
indeed harbour life at some point in the past,
and that the Birkas, the winged people of
Skypea, originally came from there, as they
fled to earth for a lack of resources.
So, what about these other moons from the
astronomical model on Ohara?
Well, what if in the past, instead of 1, there
were actually 8 moons, each with its own intelligent
life form, culture and technology?
Due to some unknown event, these moons were
abandoned and/or destroyed at some point in
the past, and its different people fled to
earth to start a new life there.
Where do I get the number 8 from?
We’ll get to that in a second.
Now, as it so happens, we actually do know
a variety of humanoid races inhabiting the
one piece world, that all have their own culture,
history and traditions.
The Giants, the Fishmen, the Tontatta, the
long limb tribes, the minks, the Sky people,
humans as well as a number of other potential
races, such as the three eyed tribe and possibly
even a demon or devil race.
Each of these groups could have originally
inhabited their very own world on each of
the moons.
And this concept is actually nothing new.
If you watched my video on Shanks, you will
know that Oda draws a lot of inspiration from
nordic mythology.
And one of the most important elements of
nordic mythology is yggdrasil, the world tree
that harbours a total of nine connected worlds.
The world in the centre is Midgard, the realm
of men, and around it eight worlds inhabited
by other races.
These races also include dwarfs and giants,
that as a matter of fact, we already know
to live in the One Piece world.
And especially the giants as well as their
island Elbaf have CLEARLY been inspired by
nordic mythology.
This also includes a gigantuous tree, that
is being hinted at in this scene here.
Could this be a reference to Yggdrasil and
the 9 worlds?
I think it’s quite likely, and notably,
one of these worlds also harbours a race of
demons.
Now, being forced to leave their own worlds
behind, each of these races will have come
down to earth, the world of humans and the
last inhabitable place left.
Here, the different people lived in constant
conflict and war with each other born from
never-ending power struggles and deep-rooted
prejudice.
One day, a charismatic and powerful leader
enters the stage and starts gathering members
of all the different races under his flag.
This diverse and unprecedented group starts
to grow in influence and popularity due to
its shared wisdom, friendship and equality.
At some point, it grows so large and influential
that it establishes a kingdom that grows into
a place of peace and prosperity.
And the leader of this kingdom is a man known
by the name of Joyboy.
Joy Boy’s ultimate goal is to unite all
the different races and bring the endless
violence and waring amongst them to a close,
end segregation and racism and create a united
world of freedom and justice, so arguably
what the story of One Piece will in the end
be all about.
We do know that Joy Boy was starting to fulfil
this plan as he promised the fishmen to bring
them up to the surface and give them equal
rights.
However with the growing influence of the
ancient kingdom and its ideals of equality
and freedman, the kingdoms of the humans started
to feel threatened and planned to overthrow
Joy Boy. 20 of them banded together to declare
war on the ancient kingdom, but initially
failed due to its immense shared wisdom, power
and technology.
However, when the war threatened to be lost,
they were unexpectedly offered help by the
king of the demon clan, which was despised
and feared by all the other races.
He offered the kings to share the powers of
his people with them, in order to turn the
tides against the ancient kingdom and make
them the gods and new rulers of the entire
world.
All of this however under one condition, that
he would become the one true king, ruling
form the shadows.
Blinded by power, 19 of the 20 kings took
the deal and so the demon king bestowed upon
them the power of the devil fruits.
One of them however, the king of Alabasta,
was wary of the devil and his power and secretly
decided to inform Joy boy about the coming
threat.
Upon hearing about the new powers of their
enemies and their inevitable defeat, joy boy
decided to do everything in his power to ensure
that his vision would be made reality some
day.
The Kozuki clan, that were part of his kingdom,
created the poneglyphs with instructions and
information about the true history of the
world.
Meanwhile, using its advanced technology,
the ancient kingdom created 3 powerful weapons
to oppose the power of the devil fruits.
The powers of Poseidon to command powerful
sea monsters, inherited by the fishmen.
The power of Pluton, a mighty battle shit,
capable of destroying entire islands, as well
as Uranos, a weapon of unknown power that
might have enabled space travel.
And finally, some secret was hidden on an
island, that would later become known as Laugh
Tale.
As Joy Boy had feared, the tides of the war
quickly changed with the sudden appearance
of the devil fruit powers.
With their help, the kings artificially changed
the geography of the entire world to ensure
their rule and position of power for centuries
to come.
And so the ancient kingdom fell, and the world
had to wait for the return of a new Joy Boy